here's what here's what really worries  me like the the combination of things  happening because on one hand there's an  escalation of it's not just your  opinions that are harmful it's your very  presence and then we're being told that  all mega republicans which is most  republicans are extremists and a threat  to democracy for voting is a threat to  democracy uh we're being told that if if  if conservatives simply  speak and present arguments or actually  present facts that were terrorists  stochastic terrorists is the phrase now  that they like to use uh libs a tic toc  as you point out she got kicked off of  twitter they didn't even give her a  reason they just said you're gone  and then on top of that so that's what's  happening and then also there's another  escalation in just the total lack of  accountability on the left and you know  we're sort of used to that but it's it  seemed to be worse now than it's ever  been where there's just they can do  whatever they want